we have seen so far two ways of  estimating an unknown parameter we can  use the maximum a-posteriori probability  estimate or we can use the conditional  expectation that is the mean of the  posterior distribution these were in  some sense arbitrary choices how about  imposing a performance criterion and  then finding an estimate which is  optimal with respect to that criterion  this is what we will be doing in this  lecture we introduce a specific  performance criterion the expected value  of the squared estimation error and we  look for an estimator that is optimal  under this criterion it turns out that  the optimal estimator is the conditional  expectation and this is why we have been  calling it the least mean squares  estimator it plays a central role  because it is a canonical way of  estimating unknown random variables we  will study some of its theoretical  properties and we will also illustrate  its use and the associated performance  analysis in the context of an example